Je veux te donner une écriture à part ça ne peut pas
être mauvais j'aimerais que ce soit très mauvais
pas parce qu'elle s'est arrêtée pour toi n'est-ce pas
oh ça me manque de faire le lit hier soir es-tu en
colère contre moi je suppose que je pense que Ruby n'est pas
ta maison peux-tu la voir et je la vois ce sont
de vraies personnes
air
pow c'est l'amour c'est magique écris quelque chose
sur elle et vois si ça se réalise si c'est le
cas alors tu as raison ne parle que
français
pourquoi vous Maga ils viennent
monsieur c'était ça dire que tu as manifesté une femme
avec ton esprit
maman va paniquer tu peux faire  à travers
n'importe quoi pour les hommes partout dis moi que
tu ne vas pas laisser passer ça
c'est l'histoire vraie et impossible de mon
très grand amour
on peut penser que c'est magique
ce que tomber amoureux est un acte de
magie tu as un nom  Ruby
sera Bowie mais ne me dis pas comment ça se termine d'
accord